it's wonderful to be here wonderful to
see so many faces that I've come to love
over the years my advisor my family's
here my mom brother you know I did ask
security to make sure my dad doesn't
he's not allowed in but he somehow found
is is his way in so good job the topic
of today's talk reminds me of something
my dad once told me I wrote it down
fewer those who see with their own eyes
and feel with their own hearts no wait
that that actually was Albert Einstein
different different jus similar haircut
for those somewhere you know there's a
is the same as an old saying that goes
give a man a fish and you feed him for a
day teach a man to fish and you feed him
for a lifetime
little-known fact it actually goes on to
say so that he may never discover how
much he loves steak or vegetarian
lasagna for those of you who are
vegetarian in the audience and the key
there the key idea is society tries to
impose lessons to teach to drive the
human being each of us but it's you
discovering your passion is the key and
that's what the talk I'd like to talk
about today and there'll be a lot of
poems throughout and the central poem by
shel silverstein called the voice is one
I think that will resonate throughout
the talk there's a voice inside of you
the whispers all day long I feel that
this is right for me I know that this is
wrong no teacher preacher parent friend
or wise man can decide what's right for
you just listen to the voice that speaks
inside this is precisely the voice I'd
like to talk about
in this in this brief little time we
have together over two small topics life
and artificial intelligence now from an
optimization perspective and one of my
co advisers has always told me when you
show a plot you have to describe the x
axis and the y axis as a good engineer
there you go that's lesson number one
the x axis is competence the y axis is
confidence and this there's a something
called the dunning-kruger effect which
is captured by this plot and that is at
the beginning of your journey of
competence when you're not very good at
something when you're first taking the
first steps of learning something as
some of you here are in the engineering
fields you're overly confident it's the
peak of confidence and you're at the
lowest stage of actually of your
abilities of your expertise and it's
funny that I am speaking here before you
today in a place of complete sort of
self doubt and despair and not knowing
what I'm doing at all and I feel like I
have zero expertise to impart on you and
so in that sense it's it's a funny
position to be speaking with especially
some of the lessons some of the advice
I'll try to give so take that with a
grain of salt and some of you sitting in
the audience today maybe at the very
peak especially if the year at the
beginning of the college journey
university journey and I'd say to me the
biggest positive the biggest impact of
college and university education is the
dismantling of the ego that's involved
in going from that peak overconfidence
to the valley of despair that I'm
currently in oh and I should mention
that this is also the time for me and
perhaps for you where folks like dusty
askew start making a lot of sense
talking about suffering and pain
and how the really great men and women
must I think as he says have great
sadness on earth this resonates with
everybody in their undergraduate years
in engineering now the real thing I'd
like to talk about is the broader
optimization problem formed by the
dunning-kruger effect which is after the
peak of confidence and the value of
despair there's a gradient provided to
you by your advisers by your parents by
your friends your loved ones society in
general the gradient over which you're
optimized to achieve a some definition
of success this is what I call the local
optimum what everybody else tells you
you're supposed to do what everybody
else at the small scale on a daily scale
and on the weekly scale monthly yearly
and for the rest of your life tells you
what the definition of success is that's
the local optimum what I'd like to argue
is some ideas of how to break out of
that convention of how to listen just
enough to hear the lessons in society
advises friends and parents but for the
rest of it ignore their voices and only
listen to your own voice and I'll tell
you through my own story here so I was
introduced as a research scientist at
MIT and very recently I decided to step
down from MIT to do my own startup I'm
still affiliated there but sort of give
up the salary give up everything give up
what I'm supposed to be the definition
under academic colleagues of what
success is of what the pursuit of the
academic life is because I'm listening
to the voice inside and what and so I'm
speaking to you at the very beginning of
this journey again full of self-doubt
and so take with it with a grain of salt
but perhaps it's interesting to speak
from this position because I would argue
it's the most beautiful position to be
in the life the the opportunity the
freedom in the struggles that I'm
undergoing now
is really a gift that comes at the end
of this journey of college now Who am I
and and what is the dream that I
mentioned there at the end the global
optimum for me that's understanding the
human mind and engineering artificial
intelligence systems visualized on the
left here is just three percent of the
neurons in the human brain it's a
mysterious beautiful thing it it's easy
to forget how little we know about this
mystery that's just between our two
years and engineering machines that can
reason they can think that can perceive
the world is one of the ways we can
understand this this this mysterious
beautiful thing that brings to life
everything around us and the dream of
creating intelligent systems companions
ones that you can have a deep connection
with that's what drives me
that's my startup work that's what my
entrepreneurship work my research work
is focused on most of the work at MIT
and before that has been our robotics
and autonomous vehicles but now the
dream is to create a system that you can
love and they can love you back a brief
history of artificial intelligence to
give you a sense to give you a quick
review if this is a totally new field
again if your undergraduate perhaps this
is a field that you want to that you
want to take take on as your journey so
started on the theoretical end with Alan
Turing and many other ideas from
philosophy to mathematics that he
presented and from whom the field was
born and on the engineering side Frank
Rosenblatt and building the perceptron
the first machine so engineering
machines that can do some aspect of
learning
some aspect of search that we associate
with artificial intelligence and then
there's been accomplishments throughout
none greater at least to me than in the
in this at least for now in a span of
games there's been two branches of
artificial intelligence
that have dominated the field the early
days have been you can think of a search
its brute-force search it's not quite as
captivating to our imagination it
doesn't quite feel like intelligence
because as brute-force searching through
possible answers until you find one
that's optimal it's converting every
single problem to a search problem and
then bringing computational power to it
to try to solve it but nevertheless the
peak of that especially for those who
play chess especially for those who
might be a Russian is when I BMD blue
defeated Garry Kasparov Kasparov in 1997
this is a seminal moment artificial
intelligence where the game that was
associated with thought with
intelligence with reason was overcome
was the greatest champion in human
champion was defeated by a machine and
the seminal moment on the second branch
of artificial intelligence is just
learning systems systems that learn from
scratch knowing nothing without zero
with zero human assistance was able to
defeat the greatest player in the world
little sidenote
the first moment did have human
assistance in the alphago system from
deep mine and google deepmind
and then the follow-on a few months
later the system called alpha zero was
able to learn from scratch by playing
itself this is the to me the greatest
accomplishment of artificial
intelligence and I'll mention when I
discuss about open problems in the field
and then in a real-world application
like I said I've worked a lot on
autonomous vehicles this is one of the
most exciting applications with
autonomous and semi autonomous vehicles
is there's been deployments lessons
explorations a lot of different debates
this is the most exciting space of
artificial intelligence if you want to
have an impact as an engineer autonomous
vehicles is the space you'll do so in
the next in the 2020s and the quick
quick whirlwind overview of key ideas in
artificial intelligence that were key
breakthroughs so neural networks and
perceptron like I said was born in the
40s 50s and 60s with the algorithms that
dominate today's world of deep learning
machine learning have been invented in
many many decades ago in the 70s and 80s
with convolutional for the computer
vision aspect of things in the in the
80s and 90s with LS TM are a recurrent
neural networks they work with language
work with sequence of data were
developed in 90s and proven out in the
arts and then did deep learning
quote-unquote revolution the term and
the ideas of large-scale machine
learning using neural networks was
reborn in 2006 in the early arts and
then proven out in the examiner image in
that moment when computer vision systems
were able to in in the challenge of
computer object recognition image
recognition and the image net data set
in the image net challenge neural
networks were able to far outperform the
the competition and do so easily from
just learning from data and a few other
developments there's a lot of
unsupervised learning self supervised
learning ideas that were born in the 14
15 16 just a few years ago and a lot of
exciting ideas in the past few years the
past few years have been dominated by
ideas and natural language processing
with ideas of transformers
anyway this might be outside the scope
of what you you're familiar with I
encourage you to look into it
transformers in particular with natural
languages some of the most beautiful and
exciting ideas that without any human
supervision you can learn the model
language sufficiently well to outperform
any anything we've done previously to do
things like machine translation to a
level that's unprecedented is really
exciting and especially exciting is that
bigger is better meaning that as long as
we can scale compute we can perform
better and better and better and it's a
totally open question how what the
ceiling of that is and finally the most
exciting thing in artificial
intelligence is the idea you know is a
there's a concept of big bang for the
start of the universe a silly name for
one of the most incredible mystery
of our human existence same way self
play is one of the silliest names for
one of the most powerful ideas and
artificial intelligence it's the
mechanism behind out for zero is a
system playing against itself to improve
continuously without any human
supervision that is the most exciting
aspect the most exciting area that I'm
excited and I recommend if you love
learning that you explore so the open
problems in artificial intelligence and
possible solutions and one of the things
and I'll focus on number four which is
something that I am that is my dream
that is sort of my life aspiration but
I'll give a whirlwind introduction
learning to understand learning to act
reason and a deep connection between
humans and AI systems so learning to
understand there's a lot of exciting
possibilities here this is a lot of the
breakthroughs in machine learning have
been in something called supervised
learning we have a set of data and you
have a neural network or a model that's
able to learn from that data in order to
generalize sufficiently to infer on
cases hasn't seen before
you could recognize cat versus dog in
the case of domain in the domains of
like autonomous driving you can
recognize lane markings you could
recognize other vehicles pedestrians all
the different subtasks involved in
solving a particular problem now that's
all good but to solve real world
problems you have to actually you have
to deal with endless edge cases the we
human beings effortlessly take care of
that our ability to do reasoning and
common-sense reasoning effortlessly
takes care of so be able to learn over
all those education you have to do much
larger scale learning and for that you
have to be much more selective and
clever about which data you annotate
with human beings and that's the idea of
active learning same way with as
children we explore the world we
interact with the world to pick up the
lessons from it the same way you can
interact with the data set to select
only small parts of it to learn from
I'll take Tesla which is a car company
and that's using autonomous driving in
its system autopilot that uses deep
learning to learn how to solve all these
different problems I'll use them as a
case study what they're doing is quite
interesting in the space of active
learning they're creating a pipeline for
each individual task they take the task
of driving and break it apart and to now
over a hundred different subtasks each
sub task gets its own pipeline its own
data set and there's a machine learning
system that learns from that data set
and is then deployed back into the
vehicles and when the vehicle fails in a
particular case that's an edge case
that's marked for the system and is
brought back to the pipeline too to
annotate so there's ongoing pipeline
that continuously goes on the system is
not very good at the beginning but the
whole purpose of it is to discover edge
cases in the same way that human us
humans learn something and you can think
of our actually existence in the world
as an edge-to-edge case discovery
mechanism so you learn something you
construct a mental model of the world
and you move about the world until you
run up against the case a situation that
you totally didn't expect and we do
those would do that thousands of times a
day still and we learn from those and
that pipeline of active learning is
really exciting area that very few
people are working on especially in the
space of research to me that's the most
exciting in terms of scale of impact
area in the next few years learning to
act the second set of open problems in
artificial intelligence
this is where the idea of self play
comes in is learning to build systems
whether through a reinforcement learning
mechanism or otherwise that are actually
acting in the world in the case of self
play the idea is that you have a really
dumb system in the beginning that knows
nothing again no human supervision and
through randomization
you have other systems that also know
nothing but know a different set of
nothing and they compete against each
other so you can you formulate the
problem as a competitive setting and
when you have to dumb systems that
compete against each other a magical
thing happens the one that's slightly
less dumb starts winning and this little
incremental step can be repeated
arbitrarily and without any constraints
on human supervision annotation cost
without any constraints I'm having to
sort of bring the human in the loop or
bring the physical world in the loop it
can all do be done in computation in
distributive sense so you can in a
matter of hours on a distributed
computing create a system that beats the
world champion at go and in fact with
deep mind and all the games that have
they've defeated the world champion
chess not just the world champion is the
the best chess playing program stockfish
in in a matter of hours of training and
the ceiling hasn't yet been reached this
is both the exciting and the scary thing
about self play is very few times is the
ceiling ever reached what we hit is the
limits of our computational power which
is computation power especially the kind
of mechanisms that are happening now the
developments happening now are can the
Moore's law has continued in many ways
the computation if you just wait a few
years computation is increasing so we
were yet to see the ceiling of the
capabilities that these approaches are
able to achieve this should be both
exciting and terrifying okay
the total biggest open problem that
nobody even knows how to do there's this
is an example of a state-of-the-art dog
intelligence system solving a particular
problem so we know nothing how to do
about how do how do how to do reasoning
systems in artificial intelligence this
is the actually not very often talked
about area because nobody know
what to do about it there's been subsets
called program synthesis communities
that kind of try to formulate a subset
of the reasoning problem and try to
solve it but we don't know much to do
particularly common sense reasoning how
to formulate enough about the world to
be able to reason about the physics of
the world about the basic especially
with human beings human human human to
physical world dynamics just there's
millions of facts seemingly that are
intricately connected that we we learned
and we accumulate in a knowledge base
this process is a really exciting area
of research that nobody knows what to do
with the things I've described
previously don't really have anything to
do with humans necessarily the by
passion and my interest is that space
between machine and human the community
broadly could be called human robot
interaction but there's a lot of
different areas in which there's a deep
connection between a human and machine
that you all experience every day so
recommender systems from Netflix to much
more importantly social networks the
recommendation engines behind social
networks recommending what you see next
in terms of both advertisement and both
about the the content of your friends
that you see which friends you get to
see more from the personalization of IOT
of smart systems semi autonomous systems
like the test autopilot and different
semi autonomous vehicles like the
Cadillac super cruise systems whenever
you have AI systems between you and a
machine so there is a machine that does
that automate some particular tasks
there's you human that are tasked with
sitting there and supervising the
Machine and there is an AI system in the
middle that manages that and manages the
tension that dance the uncertainty the
human that all the the t-word that trust
all the mess of human beings it manages
that that
it's a really exciting space that is in
the very early days what I show there is
what my sense is where we stand in 1998
there was a lot of search engines some
of you may even be old enough to have
used them AltaVista excite ask gee is
like us and so on then Google came along
the Google search engine and blew them
all out of the water they were all
working on a very interesting very
important problem but the approach and
the fundamental ideas behind their
approach was flawed
I believe that personal assistance and a
personal deep meaningful connection
between an AI system and a human being
is that's exactly where we're at many
people have in their home and Alexa
device a Google home device but most
people don't use it for almost anything
except to play music or check the
weather many of you use Twitter and
social networks but artificial
intelligence plays a minimal role it
understands almost nothing about you in
recommending how you interact with the
platform or the advertisements you see
and autonomous vehicles robotics
platforms know almost nothing about you
so shown there is the Tesla vehicle it
knows almost nothing about you except
whether your hands are on the steering
wheel or not it's I believe it'll be
obvious in retrospect how much
opportunity there is to learn about
human beings from the devices and from
that to form a deep meaningful
connection so now to return to my value
of despair to give some words of advice
and again take them with a grain of salt
so in this context in this optimization
context my first piece of advice is to
listen to your inner voice I think a lot
of people including a lot of very smart
professors advisers parents friends
significant others have in them a kind
of mutually agreed-upon gradient along
which they push you I
it's it's so difficult for me to
articulate this in a clear way but early
on I I heard it within myself a silly
sounding crazy voice that told me to do
things one of which was to try to put a
robot in every home
there's dreams that are difficult for me
to articulate but if you allow your mind
to be quiet enough you hear such voices
you'll hear such dreams and it's
important to really listen and to pursue
them advice number two is carve your own
path
if that means taking a few detours take
the detours again this is coming from
the valley of despair so I hope this
pans out in the end but I had many
detours in music I was in a band at long
hair I did I gave a lot of myself to the
practice of martial arts and both both
music and martial arts have given me
again very difficult to put into words
but have given me something something
quite profound
it gave flavor and color to the to the
pursuit of that dream that's hard to
articulate it's because I've listened to
my instincts into my heart and pursuing
these detours some poetry to to
excessive reading like I mentioned I
took a James Joyce course here so
pursuing these avenues of knowledge
through philosophy and history that
seemingly have nothing to do with the
main pursuit and starting the silliest
of pursuits starting a podcast advice
number three is to measure measure
passion not progress so most of us get
an average of about 27,000 days of life
I think a good metric by which you
should live is to maximize the number of
those days that are filled with a
passionate pursuit of something not by
how much you've progressed towards a
particular goal because goals are
grounded in your comparison to other
human beings to something that's already
been done before passionate
Judith something is the way you achieved
something totally new and a quick
warning about passion again I'm a little
bit of Russian so maybe I romanticize
this whole suffering and passion thing
but the people who love you the people
who care for you like like I mentioned
your friends your family should not be
trusted except their love but not their
advice parents and significant others
will tell you to find a secure job
because passion looks dangerous
it looks insecure advisors colleagues
will tell you to be pragmatic because
passionate looks like a distraction from
the main effort that you should be
focusing on and society will tell you to
be to find balance work-life balance in
your life because passion looks
unhealthy advice number 4 continuing on
the unhealthy part is work hard make a
habit of working hard every day putting
in the hours there's a lot of books and
a lot of advice have been written on
working smart and not working hard I'm
yet to meet anyone who has not truly
worked hard for thousands of hours in
order to accomplish something great in
order to work smart you first have to
put in those few tens of thousands of
hours of really dumb brute force hard
work of all-nighters the key there is to
minimize stress not to minimize the
amount of hours of work and to do that
is you have to love what you do and the
final piece of advice
that picture okay it's to look up to the
stars and appreciate every single moment
you're alive at the mystery of this
world at the the beauty of this world I
again this is my perspective taken with
a grain of salt but I advise the forever
oscillate between deep profound doubt
and self dissatisfaction and the deep
gratitude for the moment for just being
alive for all the people around you that
give you their love with whom you get to
share those moments to share the love a
poem by Stephen Crane that I especially
like in the desert in the desert I saw a
creature naked beastial who's squatting
upon the ground held this heart in his
hands and ate of it I said is a good
friend it is bitter bitter he answered
but I like it because it is bitter and
because it is my heart so I would say
the bitter is the self desatting not to
think that's the Restless energy that
drives us forward and then enjoying that
bitterness and enjoying the moment and
enjoying the sweetness that comes from
eating your own heart in this poem is is
the thing that makes life worthwhile and
that is to me happiness
so with those silly few pieces of advice
I'd like to continue on the gratitude
and say thank you thank you to my
advisor thank you to this University for
giving me a helping hand there you go
and thank you to my family and all the
friends that I've had along the way
thank you for their love I appreciate it
[Applause]
I've never been introduced with this
much energy I really appreciate it yes
by the way thank you for that question
how how's your daily life affected by
the meaninglessness of it all so the
answer is yes and it's hard to use
reason to justify that life is
meaningful I think you have to listen to
like there's something in you that makes
life beautiful so if you look at
something like Elon Musk
he believes that interplanetary so
colonizing Mars is like that's what
that's like one of the most exciting
things we human beings can do and so if
you allow yourself to think what is the
most exciting thing that we human beings
can do and and and if you're and see
that the work you're doing is part of
that for me like if I were to
psychoanalyze myself there's something
in me that's deeply fulfilling about
creating intelligent systems that that's
so exciting to me that we human beings
can create intelligent systems I see
artificial intelligence as the next
evolution of human civilization and to
me that makes it somehow deeply exciting
even though eventually the whole
universe will collapse on itself or the
other the cold death of the universe
side there's something within that
that's so exciting
so my first take is I love it
how much fellow colleagues and
scientists are uncomfortable with this
question so I love it I love to ask it
just because it makes them uncomfortable
it yeah it's appreciate it it's a good
like I don't know maybe in like French
cuisine
you have to like cleanse the palate it's
a good question to ask like we're now
we're not now talking about the latest
paper we're now talking about the bigger
questions of life that the simulation
question is a nice one to do that in
terms of actually practically I think
it's there's two interesting things to
say so one it's interesting to me I'm a
big fan of virtual reality I love I love
the war I love entering worlds even
primitive as they are now that are
virtual I can already imagine that more
and more people would want to live in
those worlds it's an interesting
question to me how real do those worlds
need to become in order for you to want
to stay there and not return to the real
world so the question of the simulation
is how real do we need to simulate the
world in order for you to enjoy better
than this one that's a computer science
question that's really interesting
that's a it's a like practical
engineering question because you can
create virtual reality systems I'll make
a lot of money perhaps have a
detrimental effect on society by having
people want to stay in the virtual
worlds and then the the other question
is the physics question of quantum
mechanics of like what is the
fundamental fabric of reality and is it
you know the what does it take to
simulate that reality and that's that's
like a physics question how is it finite
as an infinite what are the mechanisms
the the underlying mechanisms there's a
goal as the law of string theory does it
go below string theory and
there's actually people that written
papers on how big a computer needs to be
in order to simulate that kind of system
and now quantum computers are coming
forward which is one of the exciting
applications of quantum computing is to
be able to simulate quantum mechanical
systems this is the question how big
there's a quantum computer have to be to
simulate the universe it's a fun but a
real physics question way out of reach
of our engineering capabilities but it's
just it's not it's a nice party over the
beer over beers think to bring up with
scientists yeah there's two things I
make scientists uncomfortable and I love
bringing up one is the simulation
question and the other is what do you
think about the idea that's become
popular recently that the earth might be
flat they get really like they get angry
actually you know he's quite outpaced by
today scientists like the greatest
science ever looking the define
greatness as when it comes to the
pursuit of an endeavor those are all
looking for the most advancement in the
field given your starting point does it
come from the journey and the work
associated or destination is there some
concept so thank you for that question
very well right now and thought out
there's a personal greatness from the
perspective of the individual for me
like for me greatness is doing what I
love that's that ignores the rest of
society it's just like to me I'm the
greatest human to have ever lived
in my own little world for having to do
the things I love and that that that
that's from my perspective and I love
this the the craftsmanship of it
anything it could be anything he's just
doing the skill so that's not about
accomplishment that's not about anything
that's about just doing the things you
love from the perspective of society
they tend to then tell stories about
these pursuits and they they like to
like greatness is something that people
invent they give Nobel Prizes give
prizes to accomplishment it kind of
tells stories about human beings about
Steve Jobs about about different icons
and some are completely ignored to
history some are glorified their history
with like over glorified I recently
found out that the Pythagorean theorem
was not in developed by Pythagoras I
read it on Wikipedia I don't know if
it's true but you know that's that's
that's an example of somebody I at least
thought was kind of an actual entity an
actual human being that was great and
associated with this idea so to me I
think greatness is doing the things you
love and the rest is just luck whether
they tell a good story about you or not
[Applause]
you
you